hi I'm relief from free code camp today
we are going to talk about what is a
network
so before we answer that question let's
take the example of two people who are
trying to communicate with each other so
what happens here when one person talks
he is creating vibrations in the air
which is the medium and these vibrations
reach the other party and that's how two
people communicate so one person talks
and the vibrations travel through the
medium and reach the other person who is
listening now in case of two computers
how do they talk they don't have mouths
yet or they can't create vibrations in
they're in the air so how do they talk
so here what we have to do is we need to
create some sort of connection between
these two computers so a connection
between two or more computers or more
devices to communicate between them is
called a network
so how do we build a network there are
multiple ways you can create a network
the easiest way is to buy a simple
wireless router and connect all of your
devices to that in this example we have
connected the desktop and printer using
cables and we have connected the laptop
using the wireless connection so these
three devices can talk among each other
easily using the wireless router so we
have just created a network
a LAN is a local area network so what
does it mean imagine you have your home
and you have your own wireless router
you got your desktop connector your
laptop connector and a printer connected
to this router and your neighbor has a
similar setup
he has his home router and desktop is
connected and he's got two laptops and
they are all in their own network so now
what happens is this network which is in
your home is a lamp it is local to your
home and this particular network in your
neighbour's house is a different lamp
so these two are two different local
area networks
we are going to talk about an
device in networking called and network
interface card or NIC
so before we talk about that I want to
give you an example of how humans
communicate now imagine we have three
different people John Bob and Mary how
do they talk when you are talking you
are using your mouth so you're
transmitting information using the mouth
and the other person is receiving the
information through their ears now how
do computers in a talk or listen they
have a device called network interface
card which acts as the ear and the mouth
of the computer so that's how computers
talk through the network interface card
now imagine you want to connect devices
across multiple cities or multiple
continents now that's a huge network and
that kind of network is called a van in
this to explain this let's take an
example of an office campus you can have
multiple buildings you know multiple
floors you have multiple computers in
this different floors so how do you
connect them you take a router and put
it in each floor connect all the
computers in in that flow to that
particular router and you take a bigger
router and you connect all of your
routers to that and that's how you can
create a small van
what is the MAC address let me remind
you this has got nothing to do with the
Big Mac or the Mac operating system now
before we get into the details let me
give you an analogy now we have three
people John Bob and Mary in a room who
want to talk now John when he wants to
talk to Mary he says hi Mary how are you
doing now when Mary listens to this
message how does she know this she has
to respond to John it's through his
voice so she she replies to John but not
Bob saying hey John I'm doing good now
if you have three different computers
who want to talk to each other they
don't have any names so to bring the
analogy of names and identification to
computers we have this concept of MAC
address which is unique to each
computers network interface card
just like humans have names which are
composed of alphabets
we have hexadecimals for representing
the MAC addresses a MAC address is six
bytes long or 48 bits it is usually
represented in this format you have one
two three four five six bytes which are
separated by a colon or you can write
two bytes together and separated by a
dot
we'll see how computers talk before we
do that I would like to give you an
analogy of how people talk in this room
we have John Bob and Mary and when John
wants to talk to Mary he says hi Mary
this is John how are you doing now when
they're in the same room they're sharing
the same medium which is the air and all
all of them Bob and made it here to this
list message but only Mary responds
because it's addressed to Mary in the
same way when computers want to talk
they share a medium in this example all
these three computers are sharing a
cable this is how networks were built in
the past so you have NIC cards for each
of these computers and they have their
own MAC addresses now let's say if a
wants to talk to be what a does is it
sends a message to B which looks similar
to this hey B you know you use the MAC
address to address B this is a talking
and here is my message how are you doing
now when this message is put on this
medium everybody on this medium can
listen to it so in this case B and C can
listen to this message now what happens
is when C looks at this message it sees
that it's addressed to B so it just
silently ignores it and B when it gets
this message it sees that oh this
message is addressed to me so let me
reply and when it decides to reply what
B does is I want to know who is talking
so it looks at the original message and
sees oh it's a who is talking so it says
hey a this is B and the actual message I
am doing good that's how computers talk
let's imagine there's a room and there
are like three different people and when
two people are talking the third person
if he tries to talk the conversation
becomes difficult for the other two
people in the same way let's say we have
three different computers on the same
network now if a was talking to B and C
suddenly transmits data to a there is a
collision and when this collision
happens the original message from A to B
becomes garbage it's of no use anymore
because there is interference so when
there is a collision that happens it
detects it and it backs off before it
tries to send the message back to B
again so this was in the original days
of the networking but later what
happened is they added the concept of
collision avoidance so in that what
happens is C before it actually starts
sending data to a it tries to see if
there is a conversation going on already
before it sends so that's C a or
collision avoidance